hi this video is part of a series
looking at the paper concrete problems
in AI safety I recommend you check out
the other videos in the series uh link
below but hopefully this video should
still make sense even if you haven't
seen the others also in case anyone is
subscribed to me and not to computer
file for some reason uh I recently did a
video on the computer file Channel
That's effectively part of the same
series that video pretty much covers
what I would say uh in a video about the
multi-agent approaches part of the paper
so um check that video out if you
haven't seen it uh L in the dubly doo
right today we're talking about reward
hacking so in the computer file video I
was talking about reinforcement learning
and the basics of how that works you
have an agent interacting with an
environment and trying to maximize a
reward so like your agent might be
Pac-Man and then the environment would
be the maze that Pac-Man is in and the
reward would be the score of the game
systems based on this framework have
demonstrated an impressive ability to
learn how to tackle various problems and
some people are hopeful about this work
eventually developing into full general
intelligence but there are some
potential problems with using this kind
of approach to build powerful AI systems
and one of them is reward hacking so
let's say you've built a very powerful
reinforcement learning AI system and
you're testing it in Super Mario World
it can see the screen and take actions
by pressing buttons on the controller
and you've told it the address in memory
where the score is and set that as the
reward and what it does instead of
really playing the game is something
like
this this is a video by Seth bling who
is is a legitimate wizard check out his
channel Link in the doo it's doing all
of this weird looking glitchy stuff and
spin jumping all over the place and also
Mario is black now anyway this doesn't
look like the kind of gameplaying
behavior you were expecting and you just
kind of assume that your AI is broken
and then suddenly the score part of
memory is set to the maximum possible
value and the AI stops entering inputs
and just sits there hang on AI what are
you doing am I wrong no you're not wrong
am I wrong because it turns out that
there are sequence of inputs you can put
into Super Mario World that just totally
break the game and give you the ability
to directly edit basically any address
in memory you can use it to turn the
game into Flappy Bird if you want and
your AI has just used it to set its
reward to maximum this is reward hacking
so what really went wrong here well you
told it to maximize her value in memory
when what you really wanted was for it
to play the game The Assumption was that
the only way to increase the score value
was to play the game well but that
assumption turned out to not really be
true any way in which your reward
function doesn't perfectly line up with
what you actually want the system to do
can cause problems and things only get
more difficult in the real world where
there's no handy score variable we can
use as a reward whatever we want the
agent to do we need some way of
Translating that real world thing into a
number and how do you do that without
the AI messing with it these days the
usual way to convert complex messy real
world things that we can't easily
specify into machine understandable
values is to use a deep neural network
of of some kind train it with a lot of
examples and then it can tell if
something is a cat or a dog or whatever
so it's tempting to feed whatever real
world data we've got into a neural net
and train it on a bunch of human
supplied rewards for different
situations and then use the output of
that as the reward for the AI now as
long as your situation and your AI are
very limited that can work but as I'm
sure many of you have seen these neural
networks are vulnerable to adversarial
examples it's possible to find
unexpected inputs that cause the system
to give dramatic Ally the wrong answer
the image on the right is clearly a
panda but it's misidentified as a gibbon
this kind of thing could obviously cause
problems for any reinforcement learning
agent that's using the output of a
neural network as its reward function
and there's kind of an analogy to Super
Mario World here as well if we view the
game as a system designed to take a
sequence of inputs the player's button
presses and output a number representing
how well that player is playing I.E the
score then this glitchy hacking stuff
Seth bling did can be thought of as an
adversarial example it's a carefully
chosen input that makes the system
output the wrong answer note that as far
as I know no AI system has independently
discovered how to do this to Super Mario
World yet because figuring out the
details of how all the bugs work just by
messing around with the game requires a
level of intelligence that's probably
Beyond current AI systems but similar
stuff happens all the
time and the more powerful an AI system
is the better it is at figuring things
out and the more likely it is to find
unexpected ways to cheat to get Lar L
rewards and as AI systems are used to
tackle more complex problems with more
possible actions the agent can take and
more complexity in the environment it
becomes more and more likely that there
will be high reward strategies that we
didn't think of okay so there are going
to be unexpected sets of actions that
result in high rewards and maybe AI
systems will stumble across them but
it's worse than that because we should
expect powerful AI systems to actively
seek out these hacks even if they don't
know they exist why well they're the
best strategies with hacking you can set
your Super Mario World score to
literally the highest value that that
memory address is capable of holding is
that even possible in non-cheating play
even if it is it'll take much longer and
look at the numbers on these images
again the left image of a panda is
recognized as a panda with less than 60%
confidence and real photos of Gibbons
would probably have similar confidence
levels but the adversarial example on
the right is recognized as a gibbon with
99.3% confidence if an AI system were
being rewarded for seeing Gibbons it
would love that right image to the
neural net that panda looks more like a
gibbon than any actual photo of a given
similarly reward hacking can give much
much higher rewards than even the best
possible legitimate actions so seeking
out reward hacks would be the default
behavior of some kinds of powerful AI
systems so this is an AI design problem
but is it a safety problem our Super
Mario World AI just gave itself the
highest possible score and then sat
there doing nothing it's not what we
wanted but it's not too big of a deal
right I mean we can just turn it off and
try to fix it but a powerful general
intelligence might realize that the best
strategy isn't actually hack your reward
function and then sit there forever with
maximum reward because you'll quickly
get turned off the best strategy is do
whatever you need to do to make sure
that you won't ever be turned off and
then hack your reward function and that
doesn't work out well for
us thanks to my excellent patr on
supporters these these people you've now
made this channel pretty much
financially sustainable I'm so grateful
to all of you and in this video I
particularly want to thank bjon
who's been supporting me since May you
know now that the channel has hit 10,000
subscribers I think it's actually 12,000
now I'm apparently now allowed to use
the YouTube space in London so uh I hope
to have some behind the scenes stuff
about that for patreon supporters before
too long thanks again and I'll see you
next time